um before i run out of time with you
because i i have like another 10 minutes
i am a i am a huge i want to emphasize
the word huge fan of the john wick
movies and
i mean i love them and so i really would
like to just spend a few minutes talking
about them because i think your work
with chad is so good
um what just got number fault
believe sir i am well aware like i am uh
well aware um so i am curious what has
it been like collaborating with chad on
the john wick films because the thing
that i think is so impressive is that
keanu obviously does so much himself and
you guys are able to do these wide shots
where you're you know you can have the
actors doing these things and it makes
this action so it pulls you in in this
visceral way that a lot of other movies
don't do
and i'm just curious if you could just
talk about making the films with chad
when i
i think i've done crimson peak and the
trailer was just coming out
and then chad called me and said
or somebody i think it was not him but
somebody called me and said you want to
go into a job interview in new york with
john wick
and i said what the [ __ ] is john week
you know excuse me language i have no
idea what it was so i flew to new york i
saw of course john week number one and i
think those guys did a fantastic job you
know was like it was like fantastic i
really liked it
so we i came to new york and then chad
say i want to shoot number two like a
bachelor movie
with a lot of action
and of course as a director of
photographer you just sold right away
like [ __ ] that's fantastic so we did
that you know i think that is the gold
or the key to shoot it wide and
beautiful
as wide as we can
and make it like you know that is my
goal with lighting all the time this
carnival you know i want to have the
light as far away as possible
i never have life
of course if you're doing a close-up of
something
i have light close to the camera but
normally all my light is far far far
away
and that's the same but he wants to do
that also shoot wide so keanu could do
what keanu have to do
and then
getting into the close-ups for for
whatever reasons super fast because
keanu is running out of speed of course
because you know he's not a stunt guy
and then we talk i think he loves
crimson peak because he loves the colors
you know he just loved this color
palette we didn't crimson pete jeff for
the john week so
we talked a lot about connor he really
likes color he won't you know he loves
this happy world
even he's like super greedy and grumpy
but
and then he likes to move the camera as
we did on crimson peak as well and we do
that until we you know he's he's a cool
guy he's and we can do you know
we talked a lot about that's another way
to work
compared to
camera because chad is his inspiration
is a lot from around the world
where i feel guillermo is much more in
his brain
but it's just two different ways to work
[Music]
and john we
you know we can do whatever we
whatever we want to do
because he's so open but like let's do
it this way and you know it is
he's a cool director you know and he's
done
not you know you've done three big
movies now it's fantastic
um i know that with john wick four uh
you guys shot like honestly four
something months of night shoots at what
point does that break
we shot 18 weeks of [ __ ] night
yeah that is for people that don't
realize that's an awful lot of night
shoots like just a lot
but you know chad is a funny guy i
really like him i love him but you know
he's one of those guys he like he like
when it's paint and it is paint to shoot
night 18 weeks you know i'm telling you
because you're just getting into like a
zombie world you're never off
you know you're always like in a kind of
something because you're shooting
from you're coming back to your hotel or
apartment like six or seven o'clock in
the morning then you're taking a half
sleeping tablet and you're sleeping to
two
and then you're
going around like a zombie in your
apartment and then you have a cold like
five foot so you're never you know
you're working all the time
and then
it was pretty it was a tough it was a
really top i think
i've never done it before i've done some
pretty crazy long night shoots on the
league of extraordinary gentlemen that
was like we had a long night shoot as
well but this is like 18 weeks i think
that's a record
and
you know we did it looks great but it's
just tough it's really tough
and
i don't think our brains is made for
that
but
again we do it for the movie
uh
and and uh
but it is it was really rough it was
tough
it looks great you know i'm really happy
about the look but it's just
yeah
well one of the things about the fourth
one unlike the first two or the the two
that you worked on previously is this
movie takes place in berlin and paris
which really open up the door it opens
the doors to the bigger world and it
also allows you to get out of new york
city and photograph
all these different things that have not
been in the first three films uh what
can you what can you tease about what
you and chad were looking to do in these
you know in berlin and paris
we want to open up the world of course
but as much as we could but those cities
are very complicated to shooting you
know there's so many many rules there's
so many things you have to get
permissions to do you know it was i
think it's easy to shoot in new york and
i thought it was difficult to shoot in
new york
but i love paris you know paris is my
favorite city in the world but it's just
very difficult to shoot there because
there's so many restrictions
then you cannot shoot there because the
people are living there you know it's
just a lot of lot of stuff but we want
to open up the world and do some
some crazy cool stuff and i think we did
that
and keanu is
amazing you know he's just a fighter
he's just like so much into a team
player
um
so
i think we did a really really good
movie but it's going to be open up the
world for sure
and there's some
coming up some cool stuff
oh i'm i'm very sure um one of the
things about the john wick films that
just blow me away every time is the way
that the stunt performers and what is
done on second unit and just the way
everything comes together to bring this
world to life can you sort of talk about
um helping to craft these action set
pieces that audiences absolutely love
yeah for example in the number three the
motorcycle fight then the brits you know
of course that was like we talked about
that
for day number one
you know
he wants to do this motorcycle chase
and we talked about where should we do
it should you know we talked about that
bridge
um
[Music]
and very very very early maybe the first
week i was on that movie we just did a
lighting test on the bridge just to
figure out how it should looks
uh and then we've
decided it looks really nice but you we
want to put those tubes we have some put
tubes on life and one and a half miles
on the bridge
and of course that's kind of a challenge
but that's
that sequence was a second unit sequence
um
and we talked about that forever you
know it's just one of those sequences i
cannot explain how we did it because
it's so complicated
but again chad had these like crazy
ideas about how to do it and he pulled
it out again and it works so fantastic
but it's a big
split between first and second unit on
this move the last one we have much less
second union
oh so you were more involved in shooting
the action
yeah we shot that much more on main unit
we have a very small second unit on this
one comparing to number two for number
three is that something that you is that
something that you enjoy shooting those
kind of action sequences yeah for sure
it's super cool it's fun to do it
uh
but when you you know
yeah i like it i think it's great
but and the reason we like to do it much
that's possible on main units because
then
we're doing the way we like it
sure
what's funny though is i spoke to darren
prescott and chad
during the john wick 3 shoot and they
both told me
that they didn't say it was the
motorcycle sequence but they both told
me they were trying to pull something
off that we're shooting soon that we
still don't know how we're going to
shoot
yeah but that was a motorcycle chase i'm
sure because we you know we have so many
discussions about how to do that it was
like
it was so [ __ ] complicated
but in the movie it works
extremely well but you know we have a
million discussions about that
uh how to do it how to do the lighting
how much inter
interactive lighting should we have from
the bridge you know it's a lot of those
discussions
um
and derek is fantastic you know he's so
cool so
that works really really well
i am also a huge fan of donnie yen
obviously donnie yen is a part of john
wick four and the thing about donnie is
he's just such a professional and he
also like keanu likes to do things
himself um can you sort of talk about
getting to work with donny and maybe
what surprised you about working with
him
i don't think anything surprised me he
was just so professional he was like he
wants to do everything as you said
exactly like january those actors that
wants to
do the fight as good as they can and
they want to do as much as possible
themselves
and i'm just like
they're not teenagers anymore those guys
you know they're doing it so well you
know it's amazing i don't you know
it's i don't know how they're doing it
but
the stunts and the fights and
of course some of the faults is going to
be saving you stunning people but you
know a lot of a lot of the staff that
did themselves
uh
and he's fantastic uh he's so into it as
well
he's he just wants to do it himself he's
there for the movie and it's like
you know you meet some people that says
oh let's do that second unit can do that
or whatever stun people but you know
he's so much since you i want to do it
myself
and
it was great to work with him was fun
today i've never met him before but it
was fantastic
and he brought a lot of good good energy
into the moon
because he wants to be in there all the
time
so i was like oh sorry
no a big pleasant to meet him and work
together with him and you know keanu is
just fantastic yeah i spoke to donnie
for a movie that had come out when he
was shooting john wick and all he did
was praise everyone working on wic and
keanu saying how professional everyone
was it was his favorite hollywood movie
that he worked on he just loved it um
no you know everybody we have some rough
days yet because you know we started
we was running into the fall you know so
we shot in some light shoes and rain it
was freezing cold but nobody was
complaining it was just like let's do it
and
it works extremely well he's super
professional and very nice guy